nur noch zwei mal schlafen dann erfahren
wir endlich das ergebnis der spd
mitgliederbefragung dann ist wieder
große und da machen wir alle wieder
buchen wenn kein wunder passiert fragt
die kanzlerin und ihr volk spätestens am
montag so sinngemäß und wollen wir es
noch einmal versuchen
nein
wollen wir nicht aber das war die immer
egal angela merkel hat ihre partei
offenbar wieder fest im griff von wegen
aufstand in der cdu konnte man ja
wochenlang lesen aufstand in der cdu 97
prozent zustimmung zum koalitionsvertrag
beim parteitag letztem montag was ist
das denn für ein aufstand
es gab stehende ovationen für die
kanzlerin nach einer komplett abgelesene
rede mit solchen highlights wir dürfen
jetzt nicht nachlassen im gegenteil wir
müssen noch eine schippe drauflegen
auf was eine schippe drauflegen und das
war schon irre konkrete stelle wirklich
den saal gerockt hat allerdings die neue
generalsekretärin annegret kramp
karrenbauer gewählt mit knapp 99 prozent
wahnsinn überlegt 99 98 mal irgendwas
chapeau
unterlegt
das sind fast 100 der kramp karrenbauer
zug rollt freunde und was haben die
delegierten die hkk gefeiert das zeigt
natürlich nur wie ausgehungert diese cdu
ist nach all den merkel jahren eine
politikerin die frei spricht mit mit
regelrechten emotionen mit gesten
wahnsinn
diejenigen die an den stammtischen oder
das müssten starke volksparteien sein
die
in der hand
auf
vierter
doch partei
riesige nehmen
kommt
schon mal eine geste mehr als mutti hkk
euphorisiert die cdu nur wegen der
theoretischen möglichkeit dass es eine
zeit nach merkel geben könnte plus ein
neues programm wobei wenn man sich den
koalitionsvertrag
wenn man sich den koalitionsvertrag
anguckt gibt es da durchaus eine cdu
handschrift über die mal zwei klassen
medizin bleibt genau wie einem mietpreis
bremse die gar nicht bremst und ein
lobbyregister kommt wieder nicht wenn
man das ist doch cdu pur
überlegen sie sich mal einen moment die
union gebe es nicht ja
er hat doch damit angefangen was man
zugeben muss die kanzlerin hat wirklich
eine erfrischende neue ministerriege
zusammengestellt oder eindeutig viel
weiblicher viel weiblicher und jünger
die basis finden es natürlich toll
ich denke die auswahl die ist sehr gut
ich denke eine aufbruchstimmung es sind
mehr frauen jetzt auch eingesetzt worden
gerade auch mit jens spahn
manchmal
ja
jens spahn merkel schärfster kritiker ab
sofort an der ganz kurzen kabinetts
leine
der schlagermove julia klöckner ist ja
meiner meinung nach als neue
landwirtschaftsministerin fast schon
überqualifiziert wirklich das für sie
sie hätte ein richtiges ministerium
verdient ist meine meinung
dann gab es noch eine riesen
überraschung mit der neuen
bildungsministerin anja karliczek die
musste sich als erfahren hat erstmal
selber googeln herr und
kanzleramtsminister wird helge braun und
der ist müssen wir sagen optimal
vorbereitet aufs kanzleramt denn er ist
von beruf tatsächlich narkose arzt ich
habe diese sachen kannst du dich aus
denkt es ist wahnsinn
es war hat den richtigen beruf gelernt
leitet das kanzleramt so also ich finde
es keine schlechte zusammenstellung
wermutstropfen es ist tatsächlich kein
einziger aus sie dabei keine aus den
neuen ländern
da haben sich viele darüber aufgeregt so
recht was dabei immer ein bisschen
untergeht eine andere deutsche region
ist im kabinett gnadenlos
überrepräsentiert will hier keine
verschwörungstheorien verbreiten
aber ich muss
deutschland wird in berlin regiert träum
weiter
das zentrum der macht ist saarland eine
popelige million einwohner aber zwei
saarländische minister zu fall
plus die neue cdu generalsekretär in
doppel zufall ein drittel des saarlandes
ist mit wald bedeckt du zwar nichts zur
sache ist aber echt unheimlich die
postleitzahl von saarbrücken lautet 6 6
1 1 1 addiert man die drei einzeln und
nimmt sie dann mal zwei ergibt dass 666
die zahl des teufels oder des satans
wenn sie mal drüber nach oder lassen sie
ist
[Applaus]